it has not registered yet uh like i said
i'm just still letting it all sink in
this is definitely a big moment in my
life and it's a turning point
so i'm just trying to collect myself
because
things are starting to roll cam anthony
you did
[Applause]
blake this is your eighth win how much
do you still love beating all of the
coaches
you know i love beating the other
coaches it's
it's what they pay me to do actually
it's
and and i love my job uh you know but
with cam i i just got to say that you
know after
this is the 20th season and i said it to
him i think last night or maybe last
week
you know it's amazing that after 20
seasons all of a sudden
it was last night that god put this
artist
not only in my life but just on this
show you know what i mean
and he he he needed this opportunity we
needed this opportunity to have someone
like him
and i i'm you know just watch yeah just
watch and see what happens now oh we'll
be watching
cam what is something that you've
learned from blake that you're going to
take with you
as your career now goes to a whole new
level it's the dancing right
the dancing for sure yeah the dancing
for sure but i'll also say authenticity
like blake has been
real from the start since the beginning
of the show like i've seen
you've just been the same doing your
thing like honest and all of that so i
just i've appreciated that and
it's something that i want to carry on
into my cool yeah
blake this is the 10-year anniversary
you are the og
of the voice looking back at your
journey here on the show you've met your
future
soon-to-be wife here on the show looking
back at this journey does it make you
emotional at all
it does you know last night they ran
this little
montage of artists some of the artists
that i've worked with over the
20 seasons of being a coach on this on
this show
and it's crazy uh and and
it's hard to take in i'm one of those
guys that and i even asked cam a minute
ago i go is this soaking in on you yet
because i'm not good at
taking things in as they're happening it
takes me some time to get away from it
to look back and go
oh my god that happened you know like
that that really happened
so that's what how it is for me it
probably won't soak in on me
until i'm not a coach someday
and uh that's when it'll hit me like all
these all these crazy things that i got
to be a part of but for now i feel like
i'm still in the
i'm still in the the factory here you
know what i mean
and and you know i i love it i'm having
a blast
soak it all in well deserved next season
ariana grande is joining are you going
to miss
mr nick jonas uh i'm going to miss
uh nick like kind of like
you would miss a skin tag you know what
i mean like it was a part of you for a
minute but you know
you need to get rid of it because it's
not natural it's not working
that's that's nick to me is a skin tag
skin
tag nick jonas it's funny that you say
that because obviously we've missed you
the last few weeks here doing press and
i've been out here busy planning your
wedding for you out here
i tried to recruit nick to sing and he
said that he was too expensive and
you're gonna have to dish it out so the
skin tag but now we've got a new singer
that's right hey hey there you go
way hotter than nick jonas that's all
i'm saying